it is election day and it is time for my
prediction in terms of the electoral map
and electoral vote count remember that
last election I was 100% correct in my
electoral map prediction doesn't mean
anything about today but I want to dive
into it with you so let's take a look at
the map let's first talk about what is
not up for grabs right and we will start
with Hillary Clinton's base Hillary
Clinton's base I have at two hundred and
fifty nine electoral votes and this
includes the west coast and Hawaii this
includes New Mexico this includes
Minnesota Wisconsin and Illinois and I'm
including Michigan in Hillary Clinton's
base I know that both campaigns have
been there over the last week and that
there is the suggestion that it is in
play
I believe that Michigan will go
decidedly to Hillary Clinton and it will
not be in play but basically uh most of
the Northeast right I mean that we've
got Vermont New York and Massachusetts
Connecticut and Rhode Island uh New
Jersey Delaware Maryland and Washington
DC as Hillary Clinton's base I am
putting Pennsylvania in the Hillary
Clinton camp Pennsylvania has not gone
to a Republican for a very long time I
do not believe Donald Trump is going to
be the first Republican in a very long
time to win Pennsylvania and then we
have Virginia where Donald Trump has
left altogether let me talk briefly
about Maine Maine splits its electoral
votes there are two districts in Maine
you get two electoral votes for winning
the popular vote in Maine and then one
electoral vote for each of two districts
currently there is one district or in
other words one electoral vote in Maine
where it is about 50/50 maybe slightly
favoring Donald Trump so I am giving
Hillary Clinton three of Maine's four
electoral votes as her base and leaving
one up for grabs this is the starting
point for Hillary Clinton which is very
strong pad we are starting with two
hundred and fifty nine electoral votes
for Hillary Clinton when she only needs
270 to win right I would definitely
agree with you here I mean the Trump
campaign would argue that more of these
states are in play like Pennsylvania
Michigan Virginia but the polls just not
do not show
at this point let's now start to fill in
Donald Trump's base what is not in play
for Donald Trump well certainly West
Virginia and South Carolina Georgia is
going to go to trump as is Alabama and
as is Mississippi Tennessee will go to
Trump Kentucky is going to go to Trump
Indiana will go to Trump Missouri will
go to Trump as will Arkansas Louisiana
both of the Dakotas Nebraska Kansas
Oklahoma Texas the big Republican prize
Montana Wyoming Idaho Utah and Arizona I
believe will end up for Donald Trump so
before we even get started we sort of
realize that we're starting with 259
electoral votes for Hillary Clinton and
a hundred and eighty eight for Donald
Trump leaving 91 electoral votes up for
grabs so now is where it starts to get
interesting for Hillary Clinton because
if we start playing with some of the
numbers if Hillary Clinton wins Florida
it's over to 88 it does not matter what
else Donald Trump wins another scenario
Hillary Clinton could take New Hampshire
and Colorado and it's over because
that's 272 electoral votes it wouldn't
matter whether Trump gets Ohio and North
Carolina and Florida or whatever else
now maybe we're gonna play it more
optimistically for Donald Trump where he
takes New Hampshire as well as that
extra electoral vote from Maine and he
takes Ohio and he takes Iowa and he
takes Nevada even in that scenario if
Hillary Clinton just wins either North
Carolina or Florida she also wins and if
you eliminate Florida and give that to
Trump Hillary Clinton could also win by
taking Colorado and New Hampshire that
would get her there and we're not even
talking about North Carolina which I
believe will ultimately go to Hillary
Clinton now as as right as a right now
Pat Hillary Clinton is ahead in Colorado
in New Mexico it's not at the 80 percent
likelihood threshold uh and of course
we're gonna give Alaska to Donald Trump
but it is very likely Hillary
Clinton is going to win Colorado and New
Mexico so I believe that ultimately this
is going to come down to essentially
four five states and those are the ones
that I want to focus on right now I
think that this is going to come down to
Ohio North Carolina Florida Nevada may
ultimately go for Clinton and in the
scenario on the screen right now would
put Hillary Clinton over the edge at 274
but it is an uphill climb for Donald
Trump tonight electoral it seems like
Nevada is one of the biggest toss ups in
this whole election of course the the
race will the numbers will start pulling
pulling in around 7 o'clock yeah so
we'll see New Hampshire that extra
congressional district in Maine those
will sort of be the bellwethers and
that's what it what's gonna give us a
big picture of what's gonna happen
tonight
unless it's really close right because
there is a possibility where if you look
at the early states and I'm gonna go
through this chronologically in a second
New Hampshire and Florida at 7 p.m. is
when they close but if it's very close
we probably won't get a call on those
and that's where things can get tricky
when you look at the closing times North
Carolina at 7:30 is another one where if
it's close it's a big deal but we may
not actually see the results uh so let's
now clear the map completely uh and we
will we will go to a blank map and let's
talk through how I believe the evening
is going to go and in terms of when we
will know now I'm gonna go by when we
will know not necessarily when it will
be called and because of this before we
even start I'm going to fill in the west
coast and Hawaii as blue because we know
that that's how they're going to go
these are states where Hillary Clinton
has a 99 percent or greater chance of
winning and those don't close until
later in the night so while they
officially won't be closing we know
what's going to happen there and as we
do our live coverage starting at 6:45
p.m. Eastern tonight I I'm very
comfortable Pat with filling in the west
coast and Hawaii blue before we even
start because that's how it's going to
go and if you're watching other news
channels they're not going to give
Hillary that 80 or so electoral college
advantage that's not going to show up in
right alley but we know for sure that
she's going to win those four states so
let's start with six o'clock where
Indiana closes I think it's a partial
closure for Indiana but it doesn't
matter Indiana and Kentucky are going to
go to Donald Trump at 7 p.m. we are
going to see Vermont go to Hillary
Clinton we are going to see Virginia go
to Hillary Clinton we will see South
Carolina and Georgia go to Donald Trump
and here's where it starts to get tricky
I believe that ultimately New Hampshire
and Florida are going to go to Hillary
Clinton we may not get that announcement
because it may be close but I'm gonna
color them in the way I think that they
will end up at 7:30
West Virginia closes and that will go to
Donald Trump North Carolina closes I
believe ultimately Hillary Clinton will
win there and Ohio closes which I am
putting in the crowd Trump side at 8:00
o'clock Maine will close I am going to
give Maine proper the three electoral
votes to Hillary Clinton and I'm going
to give Trump that one electoral vote in
Maine it's about 52 to 48 right now in
favor of Trump
it hasn't split I don't know for how
long and it hasn't gone Republican since
1988 but just to do it let's give that
to Donald Trump what do you think I
would agree uh Nebraska's also a state
that divides its vote by congressional
district and in 2008 the Omaha district
went for Obama that could be in play as
well here but I think uh three out of
four main votes going to Hillary Clinton
in the the remaining one going to Trump
also tonight at 8 o'clock we will see
Massachusetts go for Hillary Clinton we
will see Rhode Island go for Hillary
Clinton as well as Connecticut
Pennsylvania is going to go for Hillary
Clinton New Jersey will go Clinton
Delaware will go Clinton as will
Maryland and Washington DC Michigan in
spite of what you've been hearing will
go for Hillary Clinton Illinois is a
shoo-in for Hillary Tennessee will go to
Donald Trump as will Mississippi and
Alabama and Missouri and North Dakota
and thousand South Dakota and Kansas and
Oklahoma and Texas so as of 8 o'clock
our map I predict will be 253 to 161
barring that it's very close and we
don't hear about some of these until
later any disagreements so far Pat I
have no disagreements whatsoever 830
Arkansas will close and that will go to
Donald Trump and 9:00 p.m. is when some
of the big boys start coming in at 9:00
p.m. we will get 29 electoral votes in
New York for Hillary
and that would according to this map
already put her over the edge but that's
not all because at nine o'clock
Wisconsin will close in favor of Hillary
Clinton Minnesota will close in favor of
Hillary Clinton Louisiana will go Trump
Nebraska will go Trump Wyoming will go
Trump Colorado will go for Hillary
Clinton New Mexico will go for Hillary
Clinton and Arizona I keep going back
and forth on Arizona I have it in the
Trump camp I think it's possible that
Arizona will be closer than some people
are saying but ultimately I do believe
it will go to Donald Trump right a few
weeks ago when Hillary was far ahead in
the polls they were looking at Arizona
but even then it was still kind of
leading Trump so I think it'll go red
again this year and if you see this map
this is 9 p.m.
ladies and gentlemen 316 for Hillary
Clinton and 194 for Donald Trump I
believe that at 9 p.m. with the
exception that Florida may be too close
to call and New Hampshire may be too
close to call and it's even possible
that Pennsylvania will be too close to
call only because of that would we not
have an answer but I believe we will
know earlier than many people are are
predicting now at 10 o'clock we will
have Iowa closed for Trump Montana will
close for Trump Idaho will close for
Trump Utah will go to Trump and here's
my sleeper for Hillary Clinton
I believe Hillary Clinton will
ultimately take Nevada I agree because
early voting is big in Nevada and
there's been a lot of turnout from the
Las Vegas area that was at a time where
she was doing much better in the polls
over the past couple weeks even though
things have tightened up I'd have to
give her the edge and lastly as we
started with Washington Oregon in
California will officially close at
11:00 and go for Hillary Clinton as
we'll uh Hawaii and last a close but not
consequential will be Alaska at midnight
Eastern which will go for Trump here is
Pat my final map 322 to 216 in favor of
Hillary Clinton do you disagree on any
individual state here I can't really
point out any single disagreement but
it's very unlikely that the election
results are going to go this way because
if you look at any given scenario it has
about a one percent chance of happening
and that one percent chance I was right
about in 2012 that's true that's true uh
and the most likely scenario actually is
a to 69 to 69 time
which would be interesting to see it
most likely would you me of all scenario
all scenarios right but in other words
in total the most likely scenarios are
various scenarios in which Hillary
Clinton wins
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed dot-com slash TDP s I don't
really like going into glasses stores
and trying on glasses well the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I liked the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me
a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker dot-com slash TDP s it costs
nothing